for the marlins it's pablo lopez his
13th start of the season
throw an advanced metric out there for
you this is his best season based on era
plus
that adjusts to the league in ballpark
and the whole thing 43 better than the
average pitcher this year he has been
spectacular
where's donnie and mel being careful
don't want to go nuts with him but here
he starts out with a strikeout what a
way
one two
and that's fair it bounces down the
third base line and garrett will cruise
into second with a double
and that is bounced into no man's land
and charlie's gonna beat it and moving
to third is garrett hampson so the
rockies get an infield hit and now it's
first and third
with just one man out so the key at bat
is right here ryan mcmahon 2-0
and this is tapped back to the mound and
hampton will score
so he got it in play and the rockies get
an early marker antonio senzatella
so hughie told you a moment ago his last
four starts have been terrific yeah and
12 ground ball outs and that last start
against texas two and five on the year
447 that era just keeps dropping
oftentimes there's a lot of family and
friends in attendance this is a fly ball
to
left field gathered in by rymel tapia
one out
not even take a stride
mcmahon and blackman and uh ryan will
make the play two outs and then he hands
him charlie you throw it in yeah
get the outfielders involved
and dickerson bounces it up the middle
rogers is there and he fires to get
dickerson and that is all for miami in
the first we go to the second the
rockies up one nothing in south florida
the offense is not necessarily knocking
the cover off the ball this year
and rogers down
on strikes
in the box score if you will but
with the defensive positioning back home
in a sense two strikeouts in the inning
for pablo lopez three through two
for the marlins trail by a run
i know i didn't do that i'm making stuff
up now that is caught by mcmahon two
outs
it helps to be 6-3-ish
for mac good hops
and this is back in the middle of the
diamond there's that man again mcmahon
what a play
how do you like that how far i didn't
like it much at all that was tremendous
he was in left field by the time he
finished making that throw
there's garrett hampson a double in a
run scored in the first
hampson out toward left center field
dickerson going back and makes the catch
over his shoulder and tapia was nearly
at third they will double him up easily
what a play by the former gold glover
corey dickerson against his former club
now martay two on and one out
into center field dropping fast to base
hit bertie being held at
third marlins will have them loaded
bases loaded the top rbi guy up
into center field it will stay up
leaping catch out there in center by
hanson but a run will score it'll be a
sacrifice fly for jesus aguilar and
we're tied at one
two way for corey dickerson
dickerson line drive right field back
goes blackman he'll play it off the wall
in comes jazz marty around third
dickerson on his way to third with a two
rbi triple yes sir have yourself a ball
game corey dickerson here's adam duvall
oh there's more david
yeah he struggles in this situation
duval of base hit 4-1 miami they could
not buy a hit in these spots on the trip
and now back-to-back big ones they've
opened up a three-run lead
maybe another guy out in the field
this kicks away and blackman's gonna
come home
so the rockies catch a break on the wild
pitch
and it's four to two
to be a marlin
as he grounds this to second there's one
and
kind of double and they do
and that all began
with the quick move by mcmahon
at second base and rogers fire to dart
to first 4-6-3 wonderful turn
to second birdie on the backhand makes
the play
and pablo is through five marlins have a
4-2 lead
and this is line diving catch fuentes
safe
on the attempt to double up martay
what a play by fuentes
out toward left dickerson over a couple
of steps and a one two three sixth
inning for pablo lopez
sharp tonight four to two
that has to do with the fact that it's
five or six miles an hour slower not ten
you normally see with a change it gets
it done again 88 miles an hour
called strike three daza didn't like the
call strikeout number eight for pablo
ground ball to jazz up with it
he'll make the play and here's aggie lar
two two to aggie lars a line drive past
the shortstop base at left field jazz
scores martay held with nobody out
aguilary's second rbi of the night give
him 46 on this season to lead the
national league it'll bring up duvall
into right field to base it martay will
scurry home and it's now a six to two
marlins lead duvall with a couple of rbi
singles tonight i'll tell you who's back
pablo lopez back
dom nunez fly ball right field playable
in front of the track for duvall yes he
absolutely is back now to see the eighth
inning we talked about
sitting at 88 pitches and whether or not
he was going to be back out for
the 8th inning
happy to report he is
popped up
racing over is birdie was on the left
side of the infield with the shift he
makes the catch
marlins have a guy right there
jazz makes the play and pablo lopez
through eight
his longest career outing
richard wants to share that walk with me
and that's fine
i will also take credit for this game
ending double play you got it i have to
right good night all right it's a
marlins win how about that